hello everyone and welcome back to the
grand chester we are back at the blitz
event it's round 7 and it's magnus
carlsen vs. 11 Oregon after losing to
dinging round 5
Magnus bumps back by beating Nippo in
round 6 and now he faces 11 we have a
nice photo of this matchup
courtesy of Leonard Otis official
photographer of the Grantchester I here
it is you can see that 11 is very very
happy before the start of the game Hart
the safe is happy because he's facing
Magnus or maybe someone in the audience
is may be wearing a 1111 t-shirt or
something and also you can see that even
though he's rocking a white white shirt
that it has a floral pattern on the
inside so as usual 11 the most colorful
Grandmaster stays true to his intentions
so there we have it now let's check out
the game Magnus with the white pieces
opens with c4 c4 again with the English
we have Knight to f6 by 11 Knight to c3
now we have E 5 Knight to f3 and Knight
to c6 the four Knights are out we have D
3 and the d5 very popular line C
captures Knight captures and now II for
pushing the knight back with knife to be
seized by 11 and then out Bishop to e2
Magnus prepares the castle Bishop to e7
11 does the same and now Bishop to e3
continuous development we have castles
by 11 and castles by Magnus and here
Bishop to e6 and this position is has
been reached one time where a3 was
played but here a 4 is a new move by
Magnus and it is as of move 10 that we
have a completely new game so a6 we have
a 5 pushing the knight further back
Knight to d7 and now d4 striking in the
center we have e captures Knight
captures with Knight captures Bishop
captures and now Knight the c5 a nice
square for the knight
we have bishops back the e3 now offering
a trade of Queens and here we have Queen
captures on d1
rook F captors and d1 and now rook F to
d8 so here 11 was able to get rid of the
tension in the center he was able to
trade Queens and now he wants to further
trade down a draw with black against
Magnus in in the wood section guys
that and always he still has the best
pair the same his magna so he will also
be able to look for winning chances we
have Knight to d5 by Magnus
we have Bishop captures so here if he
doesn't want to give up the bishop pair
11 has to leave this knight on d5 and it
is a monster nice threatening c7 if you
for c6 then you can go to b6
so here you do you can adieu have to
take it so Bishop captures with it
captures and now Knight to d7 so here
for the moment
11th pawn structure is a little bit
better since Magnus has three point
islands now including the D isolated the
D pawn but Bishop to f4 now Magnus
threatens the c7 pawn and 11 defended
with Bishop to c6 which results in him
having three pawn islands as well we
have see characters on d6 and now rook a
to c1 threatening to jump there all the
way to c7 and here 11 goes knife to f6
if you try knife to c5 to prevent it
before just kicks the night away and you
can still reach c7 so it's not a problem
Knight to f6 puts pressure on the pawn
here and rook the c7 we have rook a to
be a to defending the b7 point and now
Bishop to f3 Magnus defends the point so
now he can activate the other rook as
well we have B 6 trying to activate the
rooks with b48 captures be captors on a5
sorry B characters on a5 b captors on a5
and an out rook to b5 going after the a
5 point we look to a 1 magnus defends it
and now Knight captures on d5 here 11
grabs the D pawn but Magnus will go
after the a6 pawn so basically 11 will
end up with a past deep on whereas
Magnus will have the outside passport
with Bishop Tadros on d5 rook captures
and now rook to e7 it's not possible to
defend the pawn so g6 making some room
for the King so you get rid of any
background issues h3 Magnus does the
same and now rook to b8 so here rook
captures an a6 and the thing that's
better is that well Magnus passed point
is Orwell far advanced then Elevens deep
on and also magnus already has a look
behind the passport so here we have
Kings to g7
and look the c6 now here Magnus is ready
to start pushing the pawn and 11 is not
interested in a passive defense with
rugby 786 and rock a7 to block the pawn
with the rook so he decides to go for an
active plan which seemingly ensures him
a draw he plays rook the b2 the idea is
the other rule comes to d2 and you don't
care if Magnus starts pushing the past
pawn because you have rook captures
captures and you have the King in
perpetual checks so here
Magnus plays a six very very interesting
stuff we look d2 d2 now threatening rook
after Sun f 2 followed by Luke actress
Angie - but Magnus continues with a 7
and here 11 just captures rook captures
an f2 so what can you do here if you if
you're not careful real characters and
g2 might might result in perpetual
checks so feel free to pause the video
here and try to figure out how to win
this position with white while I give
you a a couple of seconds so for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations it's it's a really a
nice tactical shot and for those of you
who just want to enjoy a show first
let's see what happens is it really a
draw if white just brings the Queen into
the game well you get a rope characters
and g2 with check King f1 rugby 2f to
check King that you want and now rook a
to check and now you either go back with
King to f1 and you know then the rook F
to check Rudy to check relative to check
or you go back into d1 but now rook EF 2
and now the only way to prevent mate is
as you don't have any checks you cannot
check the black King there are no tricks
the only way to prevent Ruby one mate is
to go back to King te 1 and now black
continues now you don't you don't have
Ruby you want check because of King
captures and f2 so you can just not that
you can just continue checking the white
king and it's dropped by perpetual
checks so after real captures an F to
Magnus played you have to see that if
you bring your queen into the game the
Queen would be guarding the g2 point if
there wasn't for this rook here but
where can you go with the rook rook the
c2 really impressive stuff so
congratulations to everyone who found it
and here we even have a nice photo of
this moment here you have it a Leonard
also caught this move where calls and
played rook to c2 there you have it
is still holding the rook 11 staring at
the rook and we also have a photo of a
few seconds after this moment you can
see Elevens expression after he saw rook
to c2 it's just not not the greatest
position for him and he knows it so here
there's really nothing more to do now
but it is a blitz game and they're both
low on time so of course 11 continues
with rugby captures and c2 it's doesn't
matter which rope you capture it with
real capture some video and now a eight
Queen so now if you capture on g2 of
course white just gives up the Queen and
white will be up to what white will be
up a whole rook so eleven tried h5 she
can still try and create some sort of a
fortress we have Queen to e4 by Magnus
and rook c2e2 pushing the Constance
Queen back Queen d4 check with rook to
f6 now guarding the d6 pawn and look the
f1 now attacking the pin piece and here
looked a 5 by 11 you might think rook
the e6 is better because it also adds
another protector today today the d6
pawn but it would be actually worse
because after rook captures rook
captures you will not be able to move
your look or the king for the rest of
the game if you move the King you lose
the rook and you cannot move the rook so
it's just a very awkward position white
we'll just you know improve the position
as much as he likes and only then you
know enter the game you can even try
something like this if black wants to
stop that he will have to further weaken
with with the g5 and it will just be a
very quick death for black so here 11
try to look a 5 this is better but it
does involve giving up the d6 pawn so
Magnus captured will capture screen
captures and now Queen captures on d6
with check
we have rook the east six now attacking
whites Queen and now Queen to f8 we're
up to 5 11 starts the create some sort
of a fortress now King if Magnus starts
bringing the King into the game
Ruka 5 check King III we have rookie 5
check came to d4 and now look back to e
2 but now g4 we have h captures H
captures rook to G - now 11 goes after
the g4 pawn queen to h8 check we have
came to e7 and
now Quinta h3 defending and attacking
the rook rugby to check now Kings to e5
we have looked et with check King to f4
and now looked east six now hopefully 11
has created a fortress but Magnus finds
a way Magnus now wants to get his king
all the way to g7 to attack the f7 pawn
with the king and then try to create a
second attack with the Queen
so King g5 we have looked at a 5 check
King h6
we have g5 now not allowing whitey g5 in
the future so maybe the rook can set up
a defense along the 6th rank but King to
g7 we have looked back the e6 and now
without waiting for rook to g6 check
Magnus finds the absolute quickest way
to grab the f7 pawn and that's Queen to
a three check King moves with Queens the
a8 check King moves and now Queen to b7
check and it was in this position that
11 are in and resigned the game unmoved
56 as there is nothing more to do here
after we moved the King you lose the f7
pawn king captures not the rook is under
attack and here it's just lost
you could try Roxy 6th to trick white
into a stalemate but still after one
check and King moves you can even give
up the Queen captures captures because
now the King and pawn and game is
winning we'll just have a quick look
king d7 you can capture it quick King G
7 you can go King g6 and after King f8
you get these three squares and now you
just push the pawn to victory so it's
too easy to win this of course Levin
knows this and after Queen to b7 check
he resigned the game so that's another
game from the boot section of the Tata
Steel India I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Stephen green for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous video Sarah
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continue to check up on some
other games from this very nice event
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent race today